so our next topic is boosting
and boosting is is a relatively new
method as well and similar to bagging
and random forest it builds it gives
prediction models that are averages of
over trees
but there's a fundamental difference
random forest and bagging
the trees that are averaged are all
equivalent and the origin is is just
used to reduce variance with boosting
it's a sequential method and each of the
trees that's that's added into the mix
is added to improve on the performance
of the of the previous collection of
trees so that's a fundamental difference
we'll look at first boosting for our
regression trees
it's simpler to explain there
and we just think of it as a sequential
algorithm and the bottom line is with
boosting what we do is we keep on
fitting trees to the residuals and so we
improve the fit
and and so we can describe that very
easily here we start off and we try to
build a function f of x
which is going to be an average of trees
and this is in this is evaluated at some
point x so we think of it as a function
it'll start over 0 and the residuals
will just be the data observations y i
and what we're going to do is
sequentially
going from b going from 1 up to capital
b we'll just keep on going
we're going to fit a tree
with d splits in other words d plus 1
terminal nodes to the training data x
and r where r is the current residual
initially the residuals are just the
observations okay so we build a
relatively small tree to the residuals
and then we're going to update the
function by adding that tree into our
current model so our current model
starts with zero and now repeatedly
we're going to add in the tree that
we've just grown
and when we add it in we actually shrink
it down by a factor lambda
so there's these two components growing
a tree to the residuals and then adding
in some shrunken version of it into your
current model that lab is pretty small
right it's like we're going to see about
.01 for example as a value of lambda so
really shrinking it down okay and then
of course you update the residuals
because the residuals will change by a
corresponding amount
and so you keep on doing that grow tree
to the residuals add it into your
function downdate the residue residuals
and continue
and you can see at the end of the day
your model your boosted model has this
form it's a sum of shrunken
trees
all be of them
grown to the data now these trees are
not independent of each other like they
were in random forests and boosting
because each tree was grown to the
residuals left over from the previous
collection of
trees okay so what's the idea behind
this procedure well uh for for a single
tree we we can fit a large tree to the
data and if we fit the data hard with a
large tree we can overfit
so in contrast to the idea of boosting
is to learn more slowly so
we start with y
we build the tree to y
and it can sometimes be a small tree but
rather than accept the full tree we
shrink it back by a lot
by for example factor 0.01
and then we take residuals and repeat so
that the idea being that instead of to
avoid overfitting we're going to fit
very slowly
and try to at each trade try to pick up
a small piece of the signal with the
next tree
so instead of trying to try to grab a
lot of signal with over with with a
large amount of fitting we're going to
it fits very slowly
in in small parts
shrinking each time in order to
to
approximate the signal without
overfitting and it as a nice
consequence is we don't actually have to
grow very large trees as we did in
random forests
quite often smaller trees fit in this
slow sequential manner will be very
effective
boosting also works for classification
and it's similar in spirit
but it's slightly more complex so we're
not going to go in detail here but
and in fact we don't go into more detail
in the textbook
but um
there's a there's a detailed section in
in our other textbook elements of
statistical learning in chapter 10 and
and you can learn about how
uh boosting works for classification
it doesn't stop you using boosting for
classification there's a r package gbm
which we use in the exercises and and
the examples and we'll use in the r
session and that handles a variety of
regression and classification problems
okay so let's see the results of
boosting for the gene expression data
these are test errors the orange curve
is is boosting depth one so what that
means is actually
each tree's got a single split sometimes
called a stump right so very very simple
tree
uh which again might seem a little crazy
but we're going to use five five
thousand of them and when they're using
this in this uh this uh sequential slow
fitting way
um
it actually does quite well the air is
about what's about seven or eight
percent
random force
uh oh sorry random fours are a little
higher here they're about 12 or 13
percent
um
using a depth two tree which means two
splits
we do maybe a little worse than the
simple stump model
so again it's quite striking that very
very simple model applied in a slow and
sequential way
at the end of it we get a an ensemble
that actually predicts very well so rob
it seems like the depth of the tree that
you use in boosting becomes a tuning
parameter exactly well thank you for the
lead into the next slide which is um
the the tuning parameters so there's a
bunch of tuning parameters trevor just
mentioned one the depth actually let me
just put them all up
so
uh well the the the third one here i've
written is what trevor just mentioned
that the the number of splits of the
tree
uh is a tuning parameter
uh the
the depth is called sometimes called d
is uh if d is one it's simply a stump
which we saw was successful in the
previous example
and if we d is larger it allows the
interaction between predictors so
typically one tries a few values of d
maybe d equals one two
four and eight that might be a typical
example depending on
on the size of your data set and the
number of predictors oh so if d is one
each little tree can only involve a
single variable right so it's it's
actually an additive function of of
single variable so there's no
interactions allowed
and if d equals two it can involve at
most two variables right so that's
pairwise interactions so yeah
interesting
so uh that's
one tuning parameter
the number of trees is also tuning
parameter
unlike in random forests where the
number of trees
you just went far enough so that you uh
until you stopped getting the benefit of
averaging right i think it's still the
case that the number of trees is not a
hugely important parameter it's possible
to overfit but it takes i think a very
large number to typically start to cause
overfitting and here we see we're up to
5000 and
not much is really happening yet in
terms of overfitting i think it's
especially depends on the problem
in some problems you'll see the curves
really going up but with classification
problems it often just levels out like
that
so the other one is the the shrinkage
parameter remember every time we we grow
a tree we don't accept the full tree
rather we shrink it back by a quite
small fraction
and typically 0.01 or 0.001 are the
choices one uses
so there's
the these three tuning parameters
one can just try a few values of each
one and
um and look at the cross validation
error for over the over the grid to
choose
good sets of parameters
here's a so i have a couple more
examples here from actually from our
earlier data mining book this is the
california housing data
looking at the housing prices and
we have the uh
the test error here as a function of
number of trees for a number of methods
we've talked about
uh
random forests m equals two do you have
to remember how many variables there are
we'll have to look in our in chapter 10
15 of our book to
to check that but the
uh using random force with only two
variables allowed at each split gives
you an error of about you know 0.39
random force with more splits and prove
things about a bit
uh gbm
gradient boosting machine this is this
the r package that does it does boosting
it's uh we'll see in the lab
uh with depth four and eight trees are
doing somewhat better
looks like it looks like they're still
on their way down as well exactly so
maybe in this example one should have
run even more trees
another example this is a spam data from
our earlier book chapter 15. this is
again a two class problem
with about 50 predictors um
what do we have here
well let's first
another case where a single tree is
really not very good right we've even
we've even truncated the scale here
because they're going on somewhere above
seven percent single tree
bagging
as we bag we level off at around five
and a half percent
random force
probably using the the um the default of
the square root of p as the number of
predictors to select it every node has
an error it reduces that by
the scale is pretty compressed half a
percent
uh and then boosting five node trees
gets another maybe half percent
so these two methods are quite good and
they're you know i think we've seen a
lot of examples they're pretty
comparable when you say in performance
yeah
those look like they might be you know
quite two different curves but actually
if you do the proper statistical tests
they are not significantly different
okay uh just actually last topic
variable the the importance of variables
how do you measure importance of
variables in trees and bagging and
boosting and
um in random forests well
um
there's no single there's no single
parameter no coefficient with the
standard error you can you can refer to
because trees use variables in multiple
places right and every time you split a
variable could could uh participate in
the split
so what's done in uh in bagging random
forces is we um
one records the
the total
drop in rss uh for a given predictor
over all splits in the tree so if
we look at all the possible splits we
would look to see whether the variable
was involved in that split if it was we
we
measure how much it dropped the rss
and that's average over all the trees
so
the higher the better
and um
it's a similar thing with with g9 index
for classification trees
so what you get is a essentially a
qualitative ranking
this is the variable importance for the
heart data and you can see the the
thallium stress test is
at a very importance of 100. things are
usually normalized so that the top
variable has 100 and you can see the
other variables are indicated here in
terms of their importance from calcium
down to
variables with lower importance so these
variable importance plots are are
quite a important part of the random
forest toolkit also used in boosting the
same plot is used in boosting
so to summarize uh we've talked about
decision trees and in using ensembles of
trees
um
they
on the plus side they're simple and
interpretable when they're small but as
we've seen the the examples we've seen
in other examples that they're often not
very competitive in terms of prediction
error
so
some some newer methods bagging random
force and boosting
use these used trees in combination as
an ensemble
and in the process they can prove
prediction area quite considerably
um and the result is that these the the
last two methods we talked about random
force and boosting are really uh
among the state-of-the-art techniques
for supervised learning
um so if you're interested in prediction
and really just prediction performance
they're very good techniques for
interpretation as we've seen they're
they're more challenging